so many border agents have gotten that
they are actually looking at seeing at
the homeland security can be impeached
that is a Herculean leap to put it
mildly but it is something right now
that shows how frustrated they are I
wanted to raise that with art de la
Cueto the national border patrol Council
vice president in art I can understand
their their you know just overall angst
but nothing's going to happen on this
unless the president dumps the guy and
he reports to the president who really
is the guy when it comes to border
policy he visited you know the Border
not for very long didn't see any
migrants end a story this is about maybe
as good as it's going to get with this
Administration what do you think
we'll see and that that's part of the
problem here you have an individual that
has had the job he hasn't done a good uh
job at it uh and he I guess he reports
back to the president what's he been
reporting that there's no issues at the
border because that's what you're
hearing from the White House you have
the president come down to the border
and immediately the agency cleans the
whole place up so they can show him hey
there isn't a problem and I think that's
what that's what we're facing here we're
facing an individual that doesn't really
care about our nation's uh borders you
have he's working with enough
individuals that are put in high level
positions that at the same time don't
care so they just they pretend
everything's nice and and pretty but you
know the reality is and you guys have
seen it we've been talking about it for
several you know uh episodes or whatever
you want to call now talking about the
issues and issues and we're seeing the
problem we're seeing the frustration
with the agents out there in the field
we're seeing the numbers continue to
grow every single time that we're on
here you you talk about hey this is
another record month it's another record
months of individuals that are breaking
our nation's laws and here you have the
Secretary of Homeland security not doing
anything about it and if anything
reporting to the White House saying that
there is no problem
that's what the problem really is quite
right about that but the bottom line is
these numbers don't change and this this
record you know reading of migrants at
the border or at least the godaway is
now over 251 000 latest month in
December no less certainly a month we
don't typically see that sort of thing
it remains out of control are you
optimistic that any of the concessions
that Mexico supposedly made to deal you
know with Asylum cases and the like and
something the president was bragging
about uh and mayorkus was bragging about
is going to yield results
you know we're always hopeful when we're
out here we're hopeful that something's
going to get done but it's been so bad
right now I think I got more chances of
growing hair on the top of my head than
I got of this Administration actually
caring about our nation's borders all
right um I think the hair thing is a
possibility but let me finally get your
sense of what happens now obviously
they're going to have these 30 000
Asylum cases processed a month I guess
through Mexico still too early to say
how that's going to go what do you think
you know but but at the same time you're
going to be processing more you're going
to be processing faster you're going to
have agents that are still going to be
preoccupied in the processing centers
and the individuals that are you know
taking advantage of it right now is the
drug cartels they control our nation's
borders and it's horrible to say it but
it's the cold hard facts they control
the nation's borders they send agents to
one area and they're going to continue
bringing drugs into the United States
that's the big worry of Ben Crenshaw of
course I don't want to have to replay
the Bible he told me we need military at
the border we need them held in and
dealing with these drug cartels and
stopping all the bad stuff that's coming
through now when I raise to the
possibility that the Mexicans aren't
going to like that the president
wouldn't endorse that he says well he's
not giving up on that what do you think
we need somebody that actually cares
about the United States our nation's
borders and people in America you know
you can sit there and say it's going to
upset other people but at the same time
they're the ones that are causing these
problems you have all these drug cartels
that are running a lot of the the border
and they're taking care of you know
paying off individuals in other
countries we need to make sure that we
defend our nation's borders we make we
need to make sure that Americans are
safe that Americans are happy got it
well said art always good seeing you my
friend artel Cueto the national border
uh Council vice president I went on
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure or that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now